chào các
bạn video này sẽ hướng dẫn các bạn là
cách định dạng kẻ khung hay còn gọi là
Border và định dạng T hay còn gọi là
Sing cho động
văn bài minh họa chúng ta là chúng ta sẽ
tạo cái giấy mời và bây giờ bắt đầu thực
hiện Chúng ta thực hiện một vài các thao
tác định dạng cho các dòng tiêu đề Ví dụ
như kinh
giữa Hay là chúng ta ta tiến hành là
chèn cái biểu tượng hay còn gọi là
symbol và dưới cái chữ giấy m chúng ta
vào
Insert chọn
symbol sau đó chọn tiếp là more
symbol sau đó lần lượt chúng ta chọn các
biểu
tượng và chọn
Insert rồi chúng ta có được cái biểu
tượng
tiếp tục chữ giấy mời này chúng ta có
thể dùng cái định dạng là hiệu ứng văn
bản chúng ta
vào home chọn test
effect chúng ta chọn kiểu kiểu nào Tìm
trên
bài tiếp tục chúng ta chọn cái bóng độ
bóng độ như bên giả mời ở phần bên trái
này thì chúng ta tiếp tục vào test
effect chọn SAD và chọn kiểu bóng
độ chúng ta tiếp tục tăng size để Hoà
tắt cái tiêu đề
này bây giờ thao tác tiếp theo là chúng
ta sẽ định dạng điểm dừng Tab cho năm
cái dòng từ trân trọng kính mời cho đến
ngày chúng ta chọn năm dòng sau đó chúng
ta sẽ tạo cái
áp trái tại vị trí là
15.5 sau đó định dạng dấ dẫn cho nó bằng
cách nhấp đôi chuột
vào sau đó chọn 2i chọn set và
ok Sau đó chúng ta nhận Tab cho từng
dòng
một Tiếp tục chúng ta sẽ định dạng hai
dòng cuối cùng là canh giữa tại một điểm
chúng ta sẽ dùng
dùng là bước nhảy canh táp cân giữa
chúng ta chọn hai dòng nhắp chọn táp C
giữa sau đó đặt tại vị trí Ví dụ như con
số
9 và sau đó chúng ta đặt con trỏ tại
Từng dòng một nhận
Tab và chúng ta kết thúc về mặt à Định
dạng Tab cho cái văn bản này vâ bây giờ
chúng ta sẽ thực hiện thao tác là định
dạng kẻ khung và tô nền chúng ta chọn
văn
bản kẻ khung thì chúng ta sẽ vào thẻ
home chọn
Border chọn tiếp là outside
Border Tuy nhiên chúng ta muốn đường kẻ
đậm hay nhạc hay nét đôi hay không liền
nét Thì chú chúng ta sẽ vào Border and
shading chọn tiếp là có thể chọn box
hoặc Sadow hoặc 3D Tùy theo cái cách vẽ
cái đường và chúng ta chọn kiểu đường
kẽ chọn màu
sắc và chọn Quick là độ đậm nhạc hay gọi
độ
rộng và chúng ta lưu ý là apply to là
paragraph tức là áp dụng cho đoạn văn
nếu chúng ta chọn test là nó sẽ kẻ khung
cho từng dòn một ha Ở đây là chúng ta kẻ
khung Cho đoạn chúng ta chọn paragraph
và sau đó chúng ta chọn Ok Hoàng tắt cái
việc kẻ khung chúng ta có được cái
khung thao tác tiếp theo là chúng ta
sẽ là tô nền cho cái đoạn văn này thì
chúng ta cũng chọn đoạn văn sau đó chúng
ta vào thẻ home chúng ta chọn Lệ
shing và sau đó chúng ta chọn
màu và Như vậy chúng ta kết thúc về thao
tác là định dạng kẻ khung hay là Border
đình dạng tô nền hay là shing cho động
văn Xin chào bạn